[Musique]
il n'aura fallu que quelques heures à
nicolas sarkozy pour préparer sa contre
attaque et l'ancien président cognait
fort je ne baisserai pas la tête parce
qu'on me reproche des faits que je n'ai
pas commis
c'est une justice je me battrai jusqu'au
bout
ici veut s'expliquer s'expliquera bon
ils sont déjà il s'est déjà expliqué
devant les magistrats visiblement ça les
a pas convaincus au me condamne à trois
ans de prison parce qu'on me prête
l'intention d'avoir fait la volonté
d'avoir eu la volonté de rendre service
à l'ami d'un ami
tout en reconnaissant que je me l'ait
pas fait c'est la force d'une démocratie
que une personne qui se sent victime de
la justice puisse s'exprimer à la
télévision c'est la force d'une
démocratie que des magistrats en toute
indépendance puis jugés sur une affaire
et moi je commenterai pas la faire
sarkozy
vous me dites pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
convaincu et c'est pas moins de répondre
ça moi je dis la vérité
alors était ce parce qu'on n'était pas
convaincant oui c'est bien sûr vie
d'adam c'est toujours ma faute je
souhaite pour nicolas sarkozy que celui
qui va le juger en appel sera pas celui
qu'il a épinglés sur le mur des copains
parce que là c'est des militants cela si
c'est eux qui le juge parce que
l'immense majorité des juges les
magistrats sont des gens honnêtes mais
vous avez d'autres qui sont des
militants gauchisme dans la magistrature
il avait des conversations qui était
assez explicite avec votre avocat
ces conversations non d'abord est-ce
qu'il est légal
est ce qu'il est normal d'écouter les
conversations d'un avocat et son client
ou d'un médecin et son patient c'est
encore un autre sujet est ce que vous
savez que notamment sur le csm qui a à
connaître de la responsabilité des
magistrats
il ya eu entre 2015 et 2018 1048
plaintes qui lui ont été adressés et 0
sanctions
là encore j'apprends qu'au parquet
général
la personne qui requerra contre moi est
une ancienne membre du cabinet de madame
yann je ne fais de procès à personne
mais est ce que monsieur hollande aurait
été d'accord pour être jugé par un
magistrat qui aurait été à mon cabinet
il ya toujours eu des enjeux personnels
terrible au sein du bnf avec des
détestations humaines des ddd de la
compétition interne et qu'est-ce qui
fait les frais de ces enjeux et cette
ambiance forcément les justiciables
je sais faire la différence entre le
comportement de certains est une
institution
je ne jamais parler de justice politique
et je n'en parlerai jamais on sait que
la droite se cherche un champion
al'approche de l'élection présidentielle
qui est dans un an
et c'est à ce moment là que tombe la
condamnation de nicolas sarkozy donc on
peut très bien imaginer que ça va être
difficile pour lui si telle était son
intention même si j'ai lu ce matin dans
son interview au figaro qu'il confirme
que ça ne l'était pas mais on voit bien
que son retour en politique est
compromis sur un plan de fonds j'ai
toujours été contre les juridictions
spécialisées
d'ailleurs il fut un temps toute la
gauche était contre les juridictions
spécialisées qui dénonçaient les
tribunaux militaires un confinement par
exemple le week end dans les
bouches-du-rhône à marseille vous le
refusez ou pas je ne suis pas favorable
mais en général suis pas favorable au
confinement d'ailleurs louis ii vous
dites non au confinement à marseille le
week-end je dis non ne s'agit pas d'un
horizon lointain et incertain
il s'agit d'un horizon de plus en plus
proche peut-être nous l'espérons dès la
mi avril auquel nous nous préparons et
le président nous a demandé de présenter
des dispositifs et des protocoles qui
pourrait permettre de rouvrir prudemment
mais sûrement le pays dans les prochains
temps la seule solution contre le coc
vide c'est vacciner vacciner matin et
soir vacciner 7 jours sur 7
parce que le problème n'est pas le
confinement le problème c'est le virus